المترجم: Dalia Nour Eldeen
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
(موسيقى)
أرى حماس، أرى تحفيز.
أرى أشخاص وقفوا على هذا المسرح،
وجميعهم محفزين داخليًا.
لكن قبل أن أبدأ موضوعي،
أريد أن أطلب شيئًا واحدًا من شخصين.
الوالد والوالدة، أستأذنكم بالوقوف.
(تصفيق)
الحقيقة لا يوجد شخص وقف هنا
الإ بفضل مساعدة الله له ثم والديه
الذين قاموا بدعمه ومساعدته.
لذلك شكرًا لكل الأباء والأمهات،
المتواجدين معنا اليوم.
(تصفيق)
موضوع اليوم هو عن الحافز.
جميعنا نعلم أن الحافز هو برنامج،
أطلقته وزارة العمل، لكن لا أعني هذا الحافز
الحافز الداخلي، الحافز الذي يدفع أي شخص
أن ينجز، وأي شخص أن يحقق أحلامه
الذي يدفع أي شخص أن يقف في هذا المكان،
غدًا وبعد غد ومرارًا في هذا المكان.
أنا أقف هنا اليوم لأني كنت محفز داخليًا.
أريد أن أقول لكم شيئاً واحدًا.
أنا لا أقف الآن على هذا المسرح وحدي،
بل معي ضيوف وهم أربعة شخصيات
واقفين هنا لأسبوع، مساكين،
أرجو أن نصفق لهم جميعًا.
(تصفيق)
سأبدأ بتعريف هذه الشخصيات إليكم.
تعتبر هذه الشخصيات هى العائق عن التحفيز
إما أننا نمر بهم أو انهم متواجدين معنا.
دعونا نبدأ بالشخصية الأولى،
السيدة (فاهمة غلط)
صفقوا لها.
السيدة (فاهمة غلط) هى إنسانة طبيعية
مثل غيرها
تمر بمراحل عدم تحفير وأحيانًا إحباط
وبمجرد أن تمر بهذه المرحلة
تأخد البطاقة الإئتمانية ثم
تشتري حقيبة ب 22 ألف
بالطبع يعلم الفتيات عمن أتحدث
الحقيبة ذات ال 22 ألف
ومرة أخرى كانت محبطة، فقامت
بشراء ساعة الموديل الالماس ب 35 ألف
بالطبع يعلم الفتيات عمن أتحدث أيضًا
عند ذهابها إلى المناسبة الأولى
فقال لها صديقاتها
"ما شاء الله ساعتك جميلة، وحقيبتك جميلة"
فشعرت أنها محفزة
فذهبت في المرة الثانية
أيضًا ساعتك جميلة، فقل التحفيز
وفي المرة الثالثة، اختفى.
إذا السيدة (فاهمة غلط)
مفهومها الخاطئ عن التحفيز
أنه البحث عن السعادة بشراء أشياء مادية
وهذا مفهوم خاطئ
أنصحك عندما تريد شيء وأنت محبط
بأن لا تفعل ذلك، اسأل نفسك أولاً
"هل أحتاجها أم لا"
كلنا نفعل هذه الأشياء.
هذه كانت السيدة (فاهمة غلط).
الشخصية الثانية التي معنا اليوم.
السيد(لا ما فيني شيء)
(تصفيق)
السيد (لا ما فيني شيء)هو إنسان
مثل أي إنسان أيضًا.
يمر بإحباط ومراحل عدم تحفيز
لكن لديه مشكلة لا يريد الاعتراف بها
لنفسه أو لوالدته أو لأخية أو لزوجته
ولا لأي إنسان أنه محبط
وكل شيء أنا بخير.
ذهب إلى العمل، فرآه المدير وسأله
ونادرًا ما يسأل المدير.
سأله: " ماذا بك ياسيد ما بيني شيء"
_"لا شيء"
_"لماذا أنت منزعج"
عاد إلى المنزل، ثم تناول وجبة الغداء
رأته زوجتة والأولاد ووالدته منزعج
ومحبط ومكتئب
فسألوه "ماذا بك؟"
_ "لا شيء"
فخرج مع الشباب لمشاهدة المباراه،
فاز فريقة وهو لا يزال مكتئب ومحبط
فسألوه: "ماذا بك؟"
_ " لاشيء"
السيد (لا مافيني شيء)
يغالط نظرية مهمة جدًا في علم النفس
وتسمى هذه النظرية باحترام الحالة
حينما يكون الشخص مكتئب ويذهب لدكتور نفسي
أول شيء يخبره به الدكتور
" عليك أن تعلم أنك في مرحلة اكتئاب"
نحن لا نقول أنه اكتئاب، الله يحفظنا منه
لكن نتحدث عن عدم تحفير، عن إحباط
عليك أن تحترم الحالة إذا مررت بهذه المرحلة
وأخبر نفسك "أعلم أنني أمر بمرحلة
عدم تحفيز" "أعلم أنني محبط".
أعطي نفسك أسبوع أو اثنين
لتأمل هذه الحالة وادرسها.
ومن ثم، ستجد نفسك توصلت
إلى أصل هذا الإحباط.
واستطعت أن تتخلص منه بمفردك
وبدون أي مساعدة خارجية.
إذا هذا السيد (لا ما فيني شيء).
ثالث سيدة معنا اليوم، وهي أحب شخصية لي
(السيدة لوامة).
(تصفيق)
واضح من إصبع (السيدة لوامة)
بأنه ليس لي دخل
- لماذا ذهبتي إلي العمل متأخر ياسيدة؟
- سبب المنبه
- لماذا عدتي إلى البيت ولم تطبخين
لزوجك ولأولادك؟
- بسببب الأولاد.
لماذا ذهبتي إلى صديقاتك ليلاً ولم تحضري
هدية لصديقتك صاحبة عيد الميلاد؟
لم أحضرها بسبب تأخر السائق.
لدى السيدة لوامة مشكلة واحدة،
أنها تمر بعدم تحفيز وإحباط وكل ما تفعله
أنها تركز فقط على العالم الخارجي.
لذلك لن تتمكن من الخروج من هذه المرحلة،
طالما دائمًا تقول أن المشكلة في الشوارع،
المطبات، السيارة معطلة.
لابد من تحمل المسؤولية في هذه المرحلة
والاعتراف وأقول بأنني السبب.
أنا لم أستيقظ مبكرًا، أنا لم أفهم الموضوع
لذلك لم أستطع حله.
أنا ذهبت إلى العمل متأخر رغم أن المدير
طلب مني المجيء مبكرًا لكني لم أستمع له.
لأنه لا يجب أن نكون مثل السيدة لوامة.
رابع شخصية معنا اليوم وهي أيضا شخصية مهمة.
(السيد محفز وأنا ماني داري)،
محفز وأنا لم أدرك ذلك.
السيد محفز وأنا ماني داري هو شخصية
عنده ما شاء الله أولاد، أب وزوج ناجح جدا.
تقول زوجته أنه أحسن زوج في الدنيا.
ويقول أولاده أنه أفضل أب في الدنيا.
ومشترك في النادي ويقوم بلعب الأسكواش ويحصل
على بطولات في المنطقة التي يلعب بها.
لكنه متوسط في رضاه عن عمله،
مفهومه الخاطئ في التحفيز بالوظيفة،
جعله سلبي في الأشياء الناجح بها.
لكي تكون أب ناجح لابد أن تكون محفز.
لكي تكون زوج ناجح أو زوجة ناجحة
لابد أن تكون محفز.
لابد أن تكون محفز في جميع جوانب الحياة.
بدلاً من أن تقوم بربط التحفيز
بمجال العمل أو الوظيفة.
حاول أن تستمد إنجازاتك أو إنجازاتكِ،
في المجالات الأخرى،
ثم قم بتقوية الجانب الذي أنت غير محفز به.
والآن انتهينا من الأربع شخصيات
الموجودين هنا لأسبوع.
ووصلنا للمرحلة التي كنت
أهيئكم لها من البداية.
أين هو الحافز الداخلي؟
أريد منكم جميعًا أن ترفعوا يدكم اليمين.
ارفعوها، لن نقول القسم، لا تخافوا.
ضعوها على البطن، على المعدة
وليس على الصدر.
حافزك الداخلي موجود من اسمه،
في جوهرك، في داخلك.
لا تعتمد فيه على أي إنسان، موجود في بطنك.
البطن حينما تمر بأي مرحلة تشعر بها.
تشعر بأنها تؤلمك أو أنك لا تشتهي الطعام،
أو تشعر بالجوع.
بطنك ستخبرك إن كنت محفز داخليًا أم لا.
هذا المكان سمي على اسمه الطب الذي يعالج
جميع الأبعاد التي لا تتطلب تدخل جراحي.
إذا لاحظت هناك تخصصات كثيرة
تتفرع من الطب الباطني.
وأطلق الرياضيون على البطن اسم جوهر القوة.
وهنا يعلم رايان وأُبي أن لاعب الكورة
يلعب يوميًا تمارين بطن.
ليس ليمتلك معدة رياضية بل لان عضلات قدمه
تستمد قوتها من عضلات البطن وهو يدفع الكورة
كذلك السباح يلعب تمارين بطن يوميًا
ليس ليظهر على التلفاز بمعدة رياضية.
بل لأن عضلات بطنه ستمده بالقوة اللازمة.
أريدكم أن تخرجوا من هنا بشيء واحد اليوم،
من الطبيعي أن تكون غير محفز وأن تكون محبط.
لا يوجد أي إنسان ناجح وانا أتحدى أي إنسان
ناجح اليوم أن يقول أنا كنت محفز طول حياتي
لا، التحفيز يقل ويزيد لكن أهم شيء
حينما يقل أستطيع أن أتغلب عليه.
وتذكروا هذه الشخصيات، هل أنا فاهم غلط
وبقوم بإنفاق المال لإسعاد نفسي مؤقتًا،
أم يمكنني الاعتراف لنفسي أنني محبط لكي
أساعد نفسي على تحليل هذا الاحباط،
وعدم الحافز هذا والخروج منه.
أو حينما ألقي اللوم العالم الخارجي، أقول
أنت أو أنتي، لولاك لما فعلت،
أم أنه يمكنني تحمل عاتق المسؤولية.
وإذا كنت محفز ولدي إنجازات أخرى،
لماذا أربط التحفيز بالوظيفة والعمل فقط؟
لابد أن أستمد الإنجازات الأخرى ولو هواية
بسيطة لكي تحفزني على النجاح في مجال عملي.
وحينما تكون تائه ولا تعرف
اين هو الحافز الداخلي؟
ضع يدك على معدتك.
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته.
(تصفيق)